soweit der film über die situation in
bayern in der schweiz engagieren sich
die kirchgemeinden stark bei der
unterbringung und betreuung von
asylsuchenden kirchenasyl gewährt sie
aber nur in wenigen fällen die praxis
ist nämlich umstritten ist jetzt
kirchenasyl ein schutz oder ein
rechtsbruch darüber diskutieren jetzt
eher bühler
er ist ehemaliger theologieprofessor
evangelisch reformierte theologie
professor er hat ihn ein manifest
christen dazu aufgerufen asylsuchende in
notsituationen auch einmal im
kirchenasyl aufzunehmen peter ruch bis
vor kurzem evangelisch reformierter
pfarrer in küssnacht am rigi
er steht dem kirchenasyl kritisch
gegenüber und sieht in der biblischen
tradition keinen freipass für die
unbegrenzte aufnahme von flüchtlingen
was sind jetzt situationen
notsituationen die so ein kirchenasyl
rechtfertigen
ja also ich denke es gibt
unterschiedliche notsituationen in der
schweiz im moment betrifft das meistens
asylbewerber die alle rechte erschöpft
haben und die eigentlich ausgewiesen
werden sollten und dann kann eine
notsituation entstehen dadurch dass die
rückweisung in ein anderes land
vielleicht schwierigkeiten stiftet
großer schwierigkeiten etwa für eine
familie die schon lange hier ist jahre
seit jahren und dann plötzlich
herausgerissen wird es kann aber auch
sein dass zum beispiel die dublin regel
schwierigkeiten stiftet zum beispiel
dass seine familie oder zurückgewiesen
wird nach bulgarien oder nach ungarn
nicht da sind ganz schwieriger zuständig
ist riet genau du hast das verdammte
dieser regel die die regel des erst
landes wo man zurückgeschickt werden
kann und man weiß in bulgarien und in
ungarn wenn das dann geschieht dann
kommt man meistens ins gefängnis sie
sind film deutlich geworden haben auch
die situation schon geschildert bekommen
von der familie
aus tschechien die eben kurzzeitig in
kirchberg im kanton zürich als sohn
bekommen hat huch was ist denn der
kritische punkt der kritische punkt ist
meines erachtens das kirchenasyl das
hatte eine tradition schon in der bibel
beginnt das im alten testament gibt es
entsprechende stellen und das war oder
dass tempel asyl die asyl städte das war
eine ergänzung zum rechtsstaat der noch
unterentwickelt war also im strafrecht
zum beispiel es galt ihre ach ja und
wenn jemand nicht vorsätzlich sondern
fahrlässig tötete dann kommt er trotzdem
eine rach muss er eine rache befürchten
und so gab es für diese leute einen
schutz region hat geschützt weil eben
keine staatliche institution das gericht
es gab kein rekurs recht es gab auch
keine also in dubio pro reo cops auch
noch nicht das kam später bei den römern
und ging dann auch wieder mal unter dem
mittelalter das im zweifelsfall für den
angeklagten oder und das ist wichtig
dass man dass man das sieht es auch eine
ergänzung zum noch nicht entwickelten
rechtsstaat und das braucht es heute
nicht das bis heute nicht mehr denn der
rechtsstaat obwohl ich durchaus starts
kriegt ich bin aber in diesem sinn
glaube ich macht der staat seine sache
gut
es gibt mehrere instanzen und es sind
auch hilfswerke zugegen bei diesen asyl
entscheiden
der asylbewerber und zum teil auch
kirchliche hilfswerke und trotzdem bin
ich der meinung dass es vielleicht einen
härtefall geben kann und dann wäre aber
eine kirche gar nicht notwendig dann
müsste ich als privatmann wenn ich
diesen menschen gegenüber stehen müsste
ich dann mich entscheiden sie zu
verstecken vor der ausschaffung das ist
ein rechtsbruch aber ein notwendiger
rechtsbruch für den ich die konsequenzen
übernehmen müsste also sie müssen wir
helfen
der rucksack nicht kirchen
da bin ich nicht einverstanden weil sie
sagen zwar sie seien starts kritisch
vielleicht bin ich dann noch stärker
starts kritisch weil ich denke ich
könnte den satz nie sagen den
rechtsstaat macht seine arbeit gut
es gibt immer wieder probleme und
deshalb glaube ich hat die kirche auch
eine funktion als eine art ich sag jetzt
mal eine art wächterin die dafür sorgt
dass der start der rechtsstaat möglichst
seine arbeit gut macht oder das kann
sich täuschen kann sich täuschen und ich
glaube von der von der politischen
philosophie her würde würden alle sagen
ein rechtsstaat ist nicht einfach ganz
gerecht er ist immer fast gerächt und da
können immer wieder entscheidungen
stattfinden die im widerspruch sind mit
den grundprinzipien die man in anspruch
nimmt und diese ungerechtigkeit
situationen wie führen dazu dass man
dann manchmal auch ungehorsam wird oder
also in diesem sinne denke ich gehört
kirchenasyl zum zivilen ungehorsam
das nehmen sie kritische loyalität in
ihrem manifest das nenne ich kritische
loyalität das heißt es also nicht eine 1
1 will den staat sozusagen zu
destabilisieren sondern ihn zu seinen
pflichten zu ermahnen sind sie ein
unkritischer test nein also ich bin
natürlich nicht der meinung dass der
heutige rechtsstaat denn wir haben der
regent der reale rechtsstaat dass der
unfehlbare wäre in meinen entscheidungen
davon bin ich weit entfernt aber er hat
so viele sicherungen eingebaut damit den
asylbewerber möglichst kein unrecht
geschieht dass ich meine die
treffsicherheit ist verhältnismäßig hoch
also immer noch bestand habe gelesen
sind 80 prozent der fälle im kirchenasyl
die nachträglich dann recht bekommen
genau ich habe das nicht nachgeprüft
aber meine frage ist schon ist das nicht
eine ungerechtigkeit gegenüber
denjenigen die dann eben vielleicht das
auch verdient hätten noch einmal geprüft
zu werden nicht ein kirchenasyl
es ist natürlich dass ich natürlich
schon klar dass das wir mit kirchenasyl
nicht alle ungerechtigkeit fälle werden
lösen können es ist dann auch relativ
man kann ja nicht sagen das soll zur
regel werden
es sind ausnahmesituationen aber diese
ausnahmen situationen helfen einzelnen
menschen aber sie sind auch eine bürde
sagte eine ermahnung des an den start
die die arbeit zu sagen besser zu machen
und das hat in diesem sinne hat
kirchenasyl eine hilfsfunktion einzelnen
menschen gegenüber aber es hat auch eine
protest funktion die die möchte ich
sozusagen vom staatsrechtlichen her
stärker betonen gibt es eine rechtliche
grundlage
nein es gibt heutzutage gibt es keine
rechtliche grundlage weil wie das ja
vorhin hoch schon betont hat der
rechtsstaat hat immer mehr diese
funktionen übernommen und deshalb ist
die kirche rechtlich gesehen kein
rechtsfreier ort und das ist rechtlich
nicht gewährt deshalb habe ich in meinem
manifest unterschieden zwischen einem
legalen und einem legitimen akt das
heißt man kann in ethisch legitimieren
man kann ihn aber nicht legal begründen
und in diesem zwischenraum ist man mit
der situation des kirchenasyls wir
hatten ja den fall in der matthäuskirche
in basel eine reformierte kirche die von
einer gruppe von aktivisten aktivisten
mit asylsuchenden sozusagen besetzt
wurde der schweiz evangelische
kirchenbund hat vor wenigen tagen ein
dokument veröffentlicht zum thema
kirchenasyl eine auslegeordnung ob ich
das gelesen aber klar drin steht wenn
eine kirche besetzt wirkt ist das nicht
eigentlich ein kirchenasyl es braucht
das einvernehmen der gemeinde würden sie
sagen da ist wirklich ende mit
kirchenasyl wenn kirchen werden der
kirchen missbraucht wenn solche gruppen
das macht
ich würde nicht sagen missbraucht aber
sie werden für einen ungeeigneten zweck
verwendet also wenn ich asyl bewerber
die abgewiesen sind mein nach meiner
überzeugung zu unrecht unterbringen
möchte dann sollte ich sie irgendwo
unterbringen wo es vielleicht nicht so
öffentlich ist und wo es vielleicht
sogar möglich ist dass man nicht ein
entsprechendes mobiliar zur verfügung
stellt da ist die kirche nicht der
geeignete ob vielleicht das
kirchgemeindehaus aber dann ist das auch
wieder schwierig wegen der
veranstaltungen die dort stattfinden
ich meine man müsste dann schon eher
irgendeine vakante ferienwohnung
auftreiben und schauen wie man dann
diesen leuten
zudem war ein scheint das recht ist
verhelfen kann
alles ist ja immer noch eine
provisorische lösung es gibt keine
dauerlösung auf diesem gebiet ich denke
irgendwann ist dann eine deadline
vielleicht ist sie nicht definiert aber
dann muss ich ja wieder versuchen bei
den zuständigen behörden zu
intervenieren zugunsten der asylbewerber
das habe ich übrigens auch schon getan
im voraus hatte zum beispiel
korrespondenz in dem man sich für jemand
einsetzt oder wir haben auch schon ganz
kurz gesagt uns bemüht mit erfolg um
eine dna-analyse um nachzuweisen ob eine
familie zusammen gehört oder nicht das
war dann der fall und die intervention
war erfolgreich und die leute kantonale
hier bleiben das gibt schon was haben
sie persönlich gemacht aber ich
persönlich beteiligen auch da habe ich
ein wenig eine andere position weil ich
denke kirchliche räume haben eine
symbolische dimension oder das ist nicht
ganz dasselbe wenn man jetzt menschen in
einer ferienwohnung ferienwohnung man
darf sie auch nicht verstecken
und wenn man leute aufnimmt im
kirchenasyl versteckt man sie nicht ich
denke man muss es man muss öffentlich
sagen dass die jetzt da sind der schweiz
haben die kirchen punkten klar in diesem
argument verstecken geht nicht das geld
ohnehin nicht wenn zb wenn man jetzt
eine person schützen will vor der
ausweisung wegen dublin wenn man sie
versteckt dann zählen diese sechs monate
frist
nicht mehr dann beginnt alles wieder von
neuem also man muss und das ist ja auch
die idee des zivilen ungehorsams man
muss öffentlich dazu stehen dass man
jetzt diese aktion vollzieht
ich habe noch nicht ganz begriffen warum
es eigentlich in deutschland so viele
fälle gibt ich denke ungefähr 500
personen im kirchenasyl lehrzeit und in
der schweiz eigentlich nur ganz wenige
im moment keinen fall
ja also es kommt drauf an wie man jetzt
rechnet also seid in lausanne gibt es
natürlich schon lange der seit über
einem jahr und in der matthäuskirche
gab's kurs diese situation aus würde
halt sagen und da widerspreche ich
vielleicht ein wenig dem kirchenbund
wenn die kirchgemeinde sich verständigen
kann mit einem kollektiv dass die kirche
besetzt dann kann das auch kirchenasyl
sein es gibt in meiner manifest habe ich
unterschieden zwischen unfreiwilligen
und freiwilligen situationen aber weil
es werden sie unterrichten würde weiters
zum beispiel in lausanne ist ja jetzt
dieses kollektiv in einer katholischen
kirchgemeinde die dem auch zugestimmt
hat und die arbeiten zusammen und dann
ist das schon auch kirchenasyl und das
erlaubt zum beispiel bis jetzt glaube
ich hab das 80 fälle gegeben wo man dass
der blind verfahren wieder neu
aufgerollt hat das in diesem sinne hat
man menschen ermöglicht wirklich ein
asylbewerbern zu schreiben und
einzureichen und das denke ich ist doch
eine eine positive folge von kirchenasyl
auch wenn das auf gezwungen ist zu vital
in deutschland muss man wohl in relation
setzen zur gesamtzahl der migration und
einwanderung und asyl aber gleich null
ist mir aufgefallen da gibt es eine
wirkliche zusammenarbeit zwischen
behörden genau ich ja ich glaube ich so
in der schweiz das ist zur schweiz nicht
gegeben nein im moment wenigstens noch
nicht und beide beide höchsten behörden
auf evangelische und auf katholischer
seite haben den kirchen also wie
zugestimmt und haben auch mit der
bundesbehörde gesorgt dass das von den
behörden toleriert wird das ist in der
schweiz so nicht der fall oder man ist
immer noch in einem bereich wo die
regeln nicht klar sind von den behörden
her
ja ich glaube das ist aber auch richtig
so also wenn in deutschland hat
natürlich die kirche trotz den vielen
konfessionslosen hat die kirche im
öffentlichen leben doch noch eine etwas
bessere position wie mir scheint als in
der schweiz
vielleicht hängt aus einer stärkere
vielleicht hängt das auch damit zusammen
und wie das verfahren genau abläuft in
deutschland weit ich mir nun zu wenig
bekannt es gibt eine härtefallkommission
bei uns gibt es eine szene
rekurskommission das ist die letzte
instanz und wenn es dann wirklich noch
formale rügen gebe dann ginge das bis
zum bundesgericht als es ist ein
mehrstufiger weg mit sicherungen und
eigentlich ist das ist das ist ja
sozusagen der dienstweg der so korrekt
ausgestaltet ist wie möglich und das
andere ist eine intervention die legitim
sein kann aber nicht egal
und deswegen glaube ich brauche keine
absprache also wenn es eine absprache
gebe zwischen kirche und staat über das
kirchenasyl dann wäre das kirchenasyl
ein rollenspiel
sie würden nie jemanden aufnehmen in
kirchen lassen
doch unter umständen schon auch so im
notfall mäßig aber dann würde ich sofort
eine andere unterkunft für ihn suchen
das wäre vielleicht ein tag in der
kirche wenn ich nichts anderes habe
was sind denn weitere kritische punkte
da wird punkte da wird doch auch eine
gemeinde dann involviert oder kann dass
die spaltungen oder problemen führen
oder natürlich also das sind so die
umstände auf die man dann auch achten
muss ich denke es gibt eine ganze reihe
von kriterien auf die man einfach achten
muss man muss achten dass man die leute
die man aufnimmt nicht
instrumentalisiert für eigene
kundgebungen holz eigenprofilierung zur
eigenen profilierung man muss schauen
dass man diesen menschen gerecht wird
man muss schauen dass die gemeinde
nichts erspielten werden oder das ist ja
auch eine gefahr dass dann frieden
unfrieden steht in der gemeinde
man muss schauen ob die nötigen kräfte
da sind denn das ist eine
herausforderung kirchenasyl auf längere
sicht ja ich würde also ich würde wenn
ich das täte von in einem notfall würde
ich die gemeinde gar nicht einmal
sondern nur den kirchgemeinderat es wird
das müssen nicht gleich alle wissen das
sehe ich nicht ein sondern es geht um
eine wie wie gesagt um eine illegale
aktion meine ich der meinung bin dass
der staat rechtsstaat in diesem
konkreten fall versagt hat und die
treffsicherheit des staates ist nie 100
prozent und der justiz das ist völlig
klar es gibt justizirrtümer und es gibt
auch verfahrensfehler dass das sei das
ist keine frage aber dass es gibt ja
auch menschen die zu den kirchen
überhaupt keinen zugang haben die gar
nicht auf die idee kommen und es gibt
auch schützenswerte menschen oder
schützenswerte schicksale die dann nicht
zum zug kommen also ich würde dann schon
eher noch ein mädchen schützen welche
die update quasi der export für
zwangsheirat droht das gibt's ja auch
das relativ häufig in der schweiz
geplant in europa überhaupt jetzt da
würde ich da würde es mir leichter
fallen zu intervenieren
da hätte ich allerdings auch mit dem
start natürlich weniger probleme das
wenig zu sagen ja eingangs gesagt eben
der rechtsstaat regelt eigentlich auch
diese verfahren wenn wir schon oft als
engagement der kirchen jetzt insgesamt
sollen sich da überhaupt bei
migrationsfragen einmischen gibt da
einen migrations kalt der grundsätze aus
biblis theologischer sicht da steht
freie niederlassung für alle
ich denke da sehen sie dann wirklich gut
ja natürlich darüber habe ich mal in
eine disco eine diskussion geführt eine
öffentliche die publiziert wurde und das
geht natürlich nicht migration auf freie
migration für alle das heißt dass g
wenn wir keinen sozialstaat hätten es
gibt zwei dinge die nicht kompatibel
sind das ist der sozialstaat und die
offene grenze
wir müssen entscheiden entweder haben
wir das eine oder das andere fan weil
die leute in den sozialstaat einwandern
und von ihm profitieren ohne dass sie
ohne dass hier etwas dazu beigetragen
haben und es ist ja interessant dass
wenn sie die programme anschauen der
rechtsextremen fremdenfeindlichen
parteien in europa egal wo frankreich
deutschland österreich
dann haben die in ihrem innenpolitisch
sozialen katalog sind die wie etwa
gleich wie die sozialdemokraten also der
front national ganz eindeutig er ist
statistisch erwünschte umverteilung aber
die fremden sollen draußen bleiben damit
es reicht für die eigenen und das zeigt
eben wie schlecht dass der sozialstaat
mit den offenen grenzen kompatibel ist
und wenn ich die wahl hätte zwischen
offenen grenzen und dem sozialstaat
dann würde ich mich für die offenen
grenzen entscheiden
da sehen sie keinen widerspruch da sehe
ich eigentlich keinen widerspruch um die
ich denke auch dass ich die beziehung
zum sozialstaat anders gestalten würde
als das jetzt her hoch gesagt hat
niederlassung für alle das ist natürlich
nicht eine eine eine politische aktion
das ist ein grundprinzip oder also dass
man mal die perspektive versucht zu
wechseln um zu sagen was geschieht in
hinsicht auf migration wenn man mal ganz
umdenkt und nicht schon gleich
einschränkungen und begrenzungen sondern
mal vom prinzip ausgeht ein eine große
offenheit und als renteria sei liege der
schicksale aus grebs gebäude und ländern
anschauen papst francisco sagt vor
wenigen tagen ein wanderer sollen die
christen als chance begreifen begegnung
dialog zwischen kultur und religion
finden sie in zeiten wo das sehr
kritisch gesehen wird mit blick auch auf
deutschland mit großen herausforderungen
findet sie das nicht
man muss immer schauen was sozusagen ein
idealist dass man verfolgen kann und wie
stark man da sozusagen aus als
grundprinzip aufnimmt ich finde es nicht
so naiv ich denke gerade im film hatte
sicher gezeigt dass die interesse diskus
für und plötzlich ganz stark werden kann
wenn leute die aus muslimischen kontext
kommen in einer kirche aufgenommen
werden das ist doch eine chance und ich
denke gegenüber der islam feindlichkeit
die wir jetzt gerade kennen solche
konkrete begegnungen zwischen muslimen
und christen im rahmen eines kirchenasyl
das ist höchst höchst schön eigentlich
eine schöne entdeckung und ich glaube da
hat der papst schon recht dass er sagt
wir nehmen fremde migranten nehmen wir
immer gleich als bedrohung wahr
und wenn wir da mal umdenken würden und
sagen vielleicht ist das auch eine
chance dann wechseln sich vielleicht die
perspektiven das glaube ich ist auch was
die migrationsrat will sie will nicht
schon ein politisches programm
formulieren sondern einfach die idee
geben stellen wir mal unser denken ein
wenig um und überlegen wir wo sind es
chancen und nicht gleich wo gibt es
beruhen
und ich glaube es entschlossen deswegen
hat die schweiz in den letzten 25 jahren
mehr ausländer aufgenommen als
deutschland welches die täter aufnahm
westdeutschland die zahl in der schweiz
proportional der emigrierten menschen
ist höher
obwohl wir aber keinen gebiet zuwachs
hatten die ddr war immerhin ein gebiet
zuwachs und die menschen waren
deutschsprachig
also wir dürfen stolz sein auf unsere
immigrations toleranz aber auch wenn man
das so sagt bedeutet das dass sie
grenzen hat
und was der papst sagt das stimmt
selbstverständlich in der persönlichen
begegnung von mensch zu mensch
wenn sie ein migrant wären ich schaue
ihnen in die augen und ich weiß dass sie
ausgewiesen werden sollen dann ist das
für mich bedauerlich aber der staat kann
nicht nach diesem prinzip handeln
sondern nach dem rechtsprinzip sonst
gerät mit der zeit alles aus den fugen
und diese unterscheidung müssen wir
einfach respektieren und der papst ist
manchmal auch ein schönredner aber sie
dürfen ich habe ein problem mit diesem
schluss kommt mit dieser argumentation
schloss kommen
sie schalten ein wenig die institutionen
aus sollen sie betonen dass persönlicher
das kann ich auch betonen aber kirche
hat auch als institution eine funktion
in diesem bereich und deshalb darf man
sie nicht ausschalten sie
sie hatte auch etwas zu vertreten gerade
in hinsicht auf sozialstaat muss sie
auch vertreten dass das eine
grundbedingung ist dient eher etwas auch
passieren kann man all jener dem herbst
wieder als korrektiv war sie haben
nochmals die rolle des rechtsstaates
betonte wir bleiben in der kontroverse
als wird weiter kontrovers diskutiert
werden
herzlichen dank für diesen beitrag zum
thema kirchenasyl jetzt gleich geht es
hier weiter mit gray markus einem der
bedeutendsten us amerikanischen
kulturtheoretiker dem gespräch mit
meinem kollegen juri steiner dar und
punk aufleben lässt